hello there you've just joined us deep
in the Amazon rainforest sweaty very hot
we found some sony speakers and their
natural habitat lying around which is
why we came to the rainforest what we
doing that we've got some non-newtonian
fluid today we're going to make some
using the cornstarch
we've got bass in within the jungle over
there oh it's getting bright let me
adjust the exposure you can go it and
I'm almost about a sony hi-fi system
we're gonna hook up the Sony speakers to
it and hopefully get that whole
non-newtonian fluid as the speaker yeah
get it just pull the top the whole top a
bigger
that's a weird feeling is not worth
we're do you done this before yeah so
after many years of filming with either
very bright lights or in direct sunlight
I've learned that filming a slo-mo with
the color white is absolute nightmare so
now it's not it's a large butter it's
red right after mixing really well oh oh
that looks weird like it yeah yeah yeah
it's so weird it's not liquid at all but
feels like ice so strange lets me try to
put as much as I can in my hand it just
locks up it's like no I don't really
know all right man
that's probably enough joking that might
be too much Ashley yes sir all right
yeah ready go
so weird innit yeah it's really weird
like once you set it off it's like oh
there you go and that just collapses
back into liquid upwards yeah
well thanks for watching that video be
sure to follow us on Twitter take a
gander at the t-shirts we've got three
today really subscribe
my eyebrows are actually keeping the
sweat off my think that is the indeed
the purpose of eyebrow evolution yeah
right well I'm gonna get smooth the
fridge yeah play some Xbox or something
yeah so finish that rising